well
it was actually right before I came to
right before I was elected I I went to
this prayer breakfast in in my hometown
and chuck Colson was the speaker I
didn't want to appear him he just got
out of jail you know and he worked for
Richard Nixon I thought well what is
this book in this guy say to me but I
was a state senator at the time I
thought you know there's going to be
1500 people there may be some of this
God stuff a rub off on me and at least
it won't hurt me to be seen by these
people and I went you know with a very
cynical attitude and I was surprised
what he said made it really really was
good I mean I I can't remember exactly
everything he said but I knew it had to
do with God and he really got me
thinking about my life and then I a year
later I got elected to Congress and I
began to get up on Sunday and go to
church and which I never did my wife was
the same way we at the time I was about
37 and you know we my dad we didn't talk
about faith at all we will actually
weren't allowed I mean he didn't he felt
that people of faith were hypocrites and
and as a result I didn't know anybody of
faith I mean I was so far gone from that
kind of environment but I you know as I
got elected i thought you know i had
been successful i had been a businessman
and and I was an athlete and I was now a
congressman and I had a pretty
successful life and I thought
I should really be happy but I was
really vague i was kind of walking
around I think Carl yah Spurs said
German existentialist I think he said
you're kind of walking around and
nothing less that's what I kind of felt
like I was walking around in nothing
less and so I went out looking for God I
didn't know what I mean who is he I mean
you know I go to this church in that
church nothing was making sense to me
and then a freshman congressman from
Texas invited me to his house one night
and as soon as I saw this couple walk in
there was a light in their eyes than I I
knew that whatever they had were selling
at night I was buying and it was this
person of Jesus and they talked about
him and I said yeah but that was for me
and then my wife she didn't become a
believer until a year later and she she
became I guess I can talk to us away in
a secular University I mean as I was cuz
I've been asked this question but I'll
anyway oh you don't have to say anything
you don't say anything but anyway my
wife said you know she taught me my
first lesson about faith because I tried
to shove my faith down her throat i said
i would say every night to her for six
months now Jan how about receiving Jesus
tonight that one about is good Shima
gets so mad at me my friends have come
over and I didn't know anybody that knew
anything about God and I'd say what's
new and I'd say you're not going to
believe this but I believe in Jesus and
they don't
and they look up and they said Tony
what's wrong with you are you nuts I
mean everybody thought I was crazy but I
pushed my wife for six months and I was
going nowhere my wife was kicking me and
my shins are so sore because I i was
saying stupid things and and chief you
know after six months I just had to stop
saying anything and then then she began
to believe six months after that I said
well why after I stopped preaching she
said well that's why when you stopped
she said when you stop saying anything I
saw that this was something special and
you had a different attitude towards me
your children life your job I knew it
was real so that's how it's how it
happened